I want to give an AI because we've been  talking about a lot here that they're  mean it I think every Pharaoh said is  like not all AI futures of an eye like  why do you want to live what what's the  point what what inspires you what what  do you love about the future  if your future is not include being out  there among the stars and being a  multi-planet species I find anything  that gets incredibly depressing if  that's not the future that we're gonna  have I'm available 24/7 yourself to help  solve issues I call me three am in a  Sunday morning I don't care that that's  that's the future that's exciting and  inspiring probably can't because  stockholders right I mean it's legal  right it's all illegal okay  [Music]  wait is that a real picture I think it's  a real photo and deer that probably is  is that true of course it happened I  think I think this is a reflection of  how like oh my god dark